hello everybody and welcome to another
python 3 basics video in this video
we're going to carry on with functions
in the last video you were showing just
a very basic function and we didn't use
any parameters in this video we're
actually going to include parameters and
give this function more
functionality so uh let's define a
function
and we're just gonna call this function
simple underscore addition
and we're gonna have num1 and num2 and
basically when you write this stuff out
it you're just making it up like a
variable name
you can pick anything you want just
write it in it's going to act like a
variable within your function so as
usual colon enter and now we will write
out this function now what we want this
function to do is just some simple
addition for us so we're going to say
answer equals num1 plus
num2
so that's going to give us our answer
variable and just for the sake of
printing out something else uh let's
also go ahead and print num1 is
uh and actually we don't need this uh
here num1 is and then num1
now what we want to do is actually
um
print our answer too so let's go ahead
and print the answer so print
answer
and now it'll print out our answer so
num1 is going to be whatever we specify
in the num1 parameter then the answer is
going to be whatever num1 plus num2 is
obviously if you put letters or string
or whatever in here it's not going to
work
so anyway
uh enter enter and we'll run simple
underscore
edition five three
so we'll save that we'll run it
and we get num1 is five and then the
answer five plus three equals eight
cool easy enough and there are no limit
to the amount of variables that you can
have or the amount of parameters that
you can have in your function
the only thing you really want to look
out for
at this point is the order of the
variables as well as the quantity of
variables
now
the order is as follows so if you really
wanted num1 to be
5 but instead you did 3 5 obviously num1
is going to be 3 not 5. now there's a
couple of things that you can do
here you can one protect yourself
somewhat
by doing something like this so you
could say
num1 equals 5 and then num2 equals three
like so and you can hit uh you can run
that
and it's going to work just like it
always has but you're not going to
really see people do this too often but
what you could do is you could say num2
num1 and so even though they're in a
different order
then we specified that we'd receive them
because we're saying it explicitly here
we're allowed to do that so num1 is
three and sure enough that did work
so that's going to work for us now
quantity is also going to be an issue so
let's just revert back to what we were
doing before 3 5
we run that that works out for us
but if we have only one variable called
we get an error simple addition
missing one required position positional
argument
by that same token if we have three five
three or four let's do that and we run
it we're gonna get another error it
takes two but three were given
so that's why
you know quantity
is a big deal
now that's going to be it for this
specific video in the next video i'm
going to be covering the default
variable assignments because default
variables
can also kind of change up quantity so
soon we'll be throwing away all the
knowledge you just learned on quantity
oh my goodness anyway hopefully you guys
enjoyed if you have any questions leave
them below as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until the next video